- Après des années de division,
leur unité face à un ennemi
commun et aux horreurs
de la guerre en Ukraine.
"Des adultes et des enfants
"Des adultes et des enfantsre é
le président ukrainien
dans un message vidéo destiné
"L'Alliance peut encore
empêcher la mort d'Ukrainiens, ,
en nous donnant toutes les armes
dont nous avons besoin."
Impatient, il a de nouveaudes ,
des avions de chasse et un
protection du ciel ukrainien.
Mais la réponse de l'OTANs à lr
de ses attentes.
L'OTAN veut éviter de se placee
avec la Russie.
se contente d'ajouter
quatre regroupements tactiques
en Europe de l'Est.
chimique, biologique
ou nucléaire de la Russie,
l'OTAN fournira de l'équipement
spécialisé à l'Ukraine
protéger. Le président
américain lance un avertissement
à Vladiépliquerons s'il utilise
des armes chimiques."
Le secrétaire général de l'OTAN
lance lui aussi un message, pros
alliés.
"La sécurité n'est pas
gratuite. En faire plus."
Le budget militaire du Canada
est encore loin de la cible
de l'Alliance. Justin Trudeae l,
sans être plus précis.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canadants ds
nos forces armées vont continuer
à augmenter, et on en aura
plus à dire en temps et lieu.a n
sur Moscou, Ottawa ajoute
160 responsables russes
à sa liste de sanctions.réduiree
des Européens envers le pétr
russe, le Canada augmentera
ses exportations d'hydrocarb00 r
d'ici la fin de 2022.
Le premier ministre refuse
d'y voir une contradiction avec
ommes déterminés
et à continuer à protéger et
à lutter contre les changements
la Russie ne profite aucunement
de cette guerre illégale.
- Justin Trudeau quitte
l de l'OTAN
sans avoir annoncé de nouvelle
contribution militaire
alliés avec un vague engagements
en défense. C'est lors du dépôt
du budget fédéral, au début
mois d'avril, que les Canadiens
mesurer
le sérieux de son engagement.is,
Radio-Canada, Bru